Transcriber: Ece Elmaser
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Merhaba, hoş geldiniz.
Hoş geldiniz Mehmet Bey.
Hoş bulduk.
Merhabalar ben Mehmet Akdağ, şefim.
Şöyle anlatayım, biraz
hikâyemden bahsetmem gerekiyormuş.
Ben 2 yaşından beri babamla beraberim.
Onun yanından hiç ayrılmıyorum.
Hatırlıyorum, çok küçük yaşlarda
babamla beraber hep hale giderdik,
balıkçı barınağına giderdik.
Orada artık o yaşlarda başlayan eğitimimin
ilk adımlarını atıyorduk.
Siz 2 yaşından itibaren babanızın peşinden
gittiğinizi anlatmıştınız.
Kapının başındaki hikâyenizi
anlatmak ister misiniz?
Şöyle çok küçük bir evimiz vardı,
2+1 iki kız kardeşim bir odada,
babamla annem bir odada yaşıyordu.
Ben salonda yatıyordum.
Salonda yatmanın artı yanlarını
şöyle anlatayım.
Babamın sabah 5′te işe gitmesini
ve beni almadan gitmesin diye aslında
ben orada yattığım yatağımdan
kalkıp yorgamı yastığımı alıp
kapının önünde yatırdım.
Babam beni almadan çıkamasın diye.
Çünkü kapıyı açarken orada beni
uyandırması gerekecek.
Onunla beraber işte işe gideyim, işi
öğreneyim de onu taklit edeyim,
onun gibi bir usta olayım diye adım
atıyorduk diyelim.
Şu soruya geçelim Mehmet Bey.
Bu kadar babanızla büyüdünüz,
birçok şey öğrendiniz kendisinden.
Onun elinde yetişmeniz en çok hangi
yetkinliklerinizi geliştirdi?
Tamam toparlıyoruz arkadaşlar.
Burada şimdi babamla yetişmenin verdiği
işte yetkinlikler diyelim.
Sınırları aşmayı öğrendim.
Babamın neler yapabileceği ile ilgili
onu geçmeye çalıştım.
Risk almayı çok sevdim.
Risk almayı bize canlı olarak göstermek
ister misiniz?
Konuya girelim, şimdi gidelim, o zaman.
[Alkış]
Öncelikle bir pilavla
ilgili bir hikâye anlatacağım.
Benim dedem çok gariban bir adam
ve bu arada hayatını sürdürebilmek için
ek gelirler elde etmesi gerekiyordu.
Bunun için mevlit ve düğün
yemeklerine katılıyor.
Babamın kendini nasıl geliştirdiği ile
ilgili birkaç örnek verecektim.
Siz de biliyorsunuz.
Onunla ilgili
şöyle şeylerden bahsedeceğim.
Babam dedeme çırak olarak yardım ediyor.
Bu mevlit yemeklerinden birisinde,
şimdiki gibi her şey için ayrı bir tabak
veya atıyorum kap yok.
O zamanlar birkaç ürünü aynı
kapta vermeyi istiyorlar.
Seçiyorlar daha doğrusu.
Babam diyor ki, “Ya pilavla
helvayı aynı tabakta veriyorlar.
Pilavı çok seviyorum.
Ayrı güzel, helvayı seviyorum, ayrı güzel.
Ama en çok sevdiğim yer
birleşim yeri,” diyor.
Birleşim yeriyle ilgili de
babam işte hep geriyi yani,
eskiden ustalarımız ne yapardı,
babalarımız ne yapardı onu düşünürdü;
bir şey üretirken de bunları düşünüyordu.
Şimdi arkadaşlar babamın bu mevlüt
yemeğinden çıkan bir
yemeğini size göstereceğim.
Çok özeldir.
Bunun içinde kavrulmuş badem, kavrulmuş
kabak çekirdeği içi,
ananas  ve bergamot var.
Hikâye şu:
Çok özel bir salma pilavımız
var arkadaşlar.
Bunun hem pirinci hem kendi
çok keyifli bir şekilde pişiyor.
Daha sonra çok çok basittir.
Mesela bununla ilgili bu malzemeleri hep
biz dışarıda kavurup sonradan içine
koyarız ki yumuşama yapmasın diye.
Buradaki hikâye ve çelişki şu
tatlı, kıtır, yağlı ve tuzluyu
bir arada getiriyoruz.
Ananasın ekşisi ile de
bunu dengeliyoruz.
Bu babamın yaptığı mevlit yemeğinden
esinlendiği bir ürün.
Diğer ürün ise babamın çıkış hikâyesinden
benim esinlenerek yaptığım bir yemeğimiz.
Burada kullandığım ürün ise
erkek incir reçeli.
Daha doğrusu, eşek yemişi de derler buna.
Üstündeki de pikan cevizi.
Şimdi buradaki aldığımız aslında hikâye,
insanların bildiği lezzetleri
bir araya getirebilme,
bunlardan beklediğimiz
şaşkınlık riskini gösterebilme.
Sende artık olay, beni bırak ya!
[Kahkaha]
Tamam, buradan farklı bakış açısından
devam edersek
bize bakmakla görmenin arasındaki
farktan bahsetmiştiniz.
Onu açıklamak ister misiniz?
Evet, öyle geleyim ben.
Bakmakla görmek,
mesela en son toplantımızda
bizim orada sohbet ediyorduk.
Şimdi ben dedim ki
etrafınızda ne görüyorsunuz,
hanımefendi dedi ki
çam ağaçlarını görüyorum.
Ben dedim ki, o çam ağaçları yaprağından
dondurma yapmak istiyorum mesela.
Çünkü orada bildiğim bir şey var.
C vitamini çok yüksek.
Çok özel bir çam kokusu var.
Onu işte atıyorum,
yemeklerde nasıl kullanırım
diye düşünüyorum,
hanımefendi kafasını sağa çevirdi
ya dedi muz ağacı var.
Ben dedim ki onun çiçeğinden
dolma yapayım.
Yani siz bakıyorsunuz
ben görüyorum ve ben onu yapmak istiyorum.
Siz inanmayacaksınız ama
sizden sonra o gün o muz ağacından
dolma yaptım.
Çok da merak ediyordum,
aklıma takılmıştı aslında.
Umarım bir gün deneme şansımız olur.
Mehmet Bey, elinizde
taze fasulyeyle gelmiştiniz.
Biraz başa dönmek istiyorum,
onun anlamı nedir?
Şimdi bunun çok
özel bir hikâyesi var bizde.
Öncelikle ben Yedi Mehmet’in doğuş
hikâyesinden size bahsetmek istiyorum.
Benim dedem çok küçük yaşta
babasını kaybediyor.
Üç tane küçük erkek kardeşi var,
bir de annesi var.
Ona bakmak zorunda kalıyor,
ilkokul ikiden terk bu arada.
Daha sonra annesi Hacı
Hasan’ın baş aşçılığını yapmış --
Atatürk’ün baş aşçılığını yapmış
Hacı Hasan’nın yanına
dedemi çırak olarak veriyor.
Yaşı 7-8 yaşlarında ilkokul 2′nin başında
okulu bırakmak zorunda kalıyor.
Dedem, o dönemlerde araba yok, motor yok,
bisiklet yok; bir yerlere giderken at,
eşek veya yaya olarak gidiyor.
Bir gün dedem eşeğe binerken
eşekten düşüyor, eşek dedemi tepiyor.
Dedemin alnında bir “V”
harfine benzer bir yara izi oluşuyor.
Aradan 3-5 yıl sonra lokantada Hacı
Hasan’nın yanında çalışıyorken
yemeğin içinden saç çıkıyor.
Hacı Hasan çok titiz
ve disiplinli bir adam
ve diyor ki bir lokantamda
böyle bir şey olamaz.
Herkese bir hem nasihat
ve bir ders vermek için
tüm çalışanların kafayı
usturayla kazıtıyor.
Gerçi benimki genetik de arkadaşlar.
Sonra  ders verdikten sonra
herkes hazır olda duruyor.
Hacı Hasan yanına çağırıyor işte,
diyor ki, “Mehmet senin alnındaki yara
izinin ne anlama geldiğini biliyor musun?”
Hayır usta, bilmiyorum.
O zamanlar eski Türkçe ve Arapça var,
Türkçe diye bir şey yok.
1920′li yıllardan bahsediyoruz.
Dedeme diyor ki, “Senin adın bundan sonra
Yedi Mehmet,” diye koyuyor.
İsmim böyle başladı.
Daha sonra arkadaşlar, taze fasulyenin
asıl hikâyesine geliyoruz.
1935, 18 Şubat.
Atatürk, Antalya’ya gelecek.
Zamanın Antalya Valisi ve Belediye Başkanı
Hacı Hasan’ın yanına gidiyorlar.
Oğlunu oradaki Çanakkale’deki askeri
ve aşçısı olduğu için ona danışıyorlar.
Diyorlar ki, ya işte Hacı Hasan,
Paşa’ya ne keselim?
Develer mi keselim, koçlar mı,
tosunlar mı?
Hacı Hasan diyor ki, “Sadece taze
fasulye ve başka hiçbir şey yok,” diyor.
Ya olur mu, olur.
Atatürk taze fasulyeyi acayip seviyormuş.
Tabii Hacı Hasan bunu biliyor.
Şimdiki gibi bağ yok, bahçe yok, sera yok.
Diyor ki, “Ya mevsimi değil, 18
Şubat olmaz, ilkbaharda.
Ancak mayıs nisanda taze fasulye çıkacak.”
Dedem bir risk alıyor.
Diyor ki, usta ben bulurum.
Allah allah, nasıl bulacak?
Yedi Mehmet atlıyor, tüm bahçe
aralarını dolaşıyor.
Tamamında sadece şurada olan 850
gram taze fasulye buluyor.
Bulduktan sonra bu şehir efsanesi değil,
gerçek bir hikâye.
Atatürk geliyor, Atatürk’e
taze fasulye sunuluyor.
Atatürk yerken diyor ki,
“Ben bu tadı tanıyorum.
Bana Hacı Hasan’ı getirin,” diyor.
Dedem ve Hacı Hasan beraber gidiyorlar.
Orada dedemle Atatürk’ü tanıştırıyor
ve bu tatta gerçekten Ata’nın
büyüklüğünü de öğreniyoruz.
Her şeyi yaptığı gibi
onu da çok iyi yapıyor.
Tadından ustasını tanıyor.
Mehmet Bey, size bir sorum daha var.
Geçmişten gelen sadece bu hikâyeler yok.
Bir de ateş var galiba.
Onu anlatır mısınız?
Tabii, şimdi dedem ustası gibi
bir usta olmak istiyor.
Ne yapacak?
Onun gibi bir lokanta açacak.
Eskiden ustaların bir el verme seremonisi
vardır, bunu uyguluyorlar orada.
Ustası dedeme mutfak malzemelerini,
hepsini hediye ediyor.
Sonra da şimdiki gibi ocak yok, tüp yok,
elektrikli ocaklar yok.
İlk odunun yakıyor.
Bu da çok özel bir şeydir.
İlk odunun yaktıktan sonra, biz
hâlâ hiç kimsenin inanmadığı bir şekilde
hâlâ o közün ateşiyle yanıyoruz.
85 yıldır hiç sönmedi.
[Alkış]
Mehmet Bey, hikâyeniz için
çok teşekkür ederiz.
Buraya geldiğiniz için de.
Afiyet olsun!